so
I've got a few questions that came in
that are around the theme of what it
means to lead now by the way I should
have told everybody that Simon did not
want to see these questions in advance
so
this is this is real time
so Bunch on what it means to lead right
now and into the future
so but the first one someone wanted to
ask is you're a leadership expert but
you're also a human being going through
this pandemic as well so how are you
doing
and how are you living and leading
through this moment
oh yeah I mean my experience is uh in
terms of emotional ups and downs is like
everybody's
when covid first started like many
businesses
um our business lost its primary source
of income we made most of our income
from Live Events and live workshops and
of course those disappeared almost
immediately and so we had to completely
reorganize and change the business we
were in
I needed to stay focused even though
there was all of this uncertainty and
craziness you know we were cleaning our
groceries every day
um so I called a friend of mine who was
uh who is active duty military and I
asked him a simple question I said when
you go to combat how do you
compartmentalize your emotions so that
you can stay Mission focused because
that's what I need to do and he gave me
a Stern warning he said we can't he said
we can compartmentalize our emotions
only for a short period of time he said
but nobody escapes the trauma of combat
and so uh I sort of called all my a-type
personality friends and said listen
um we're all going to go through this
um and so let's just all agree to call
each other if we start to feel off our
game sure enough four or five months
into covid
um uh I started to feel completely off
my game I wasn't sure what was going on
but I remember struggling to focus I
didn't know what it was so I called that
same friend and I said what are your
symptoms and he said well uh number one
he falls out of his sleep pattern he
starts going to bed really late and
doesn't want to get out of bed in the
morning and I thought to myself yep and
then he says he'll have an unproductive
day and he'll rationalize it to himself
oh you've been working really hard it's
okay to have a slow day but then he has
another and another and I thought to
myself yep
and then he said and he becomes
anti-social he doesn't want to talk to
anyone and he definitely doesn't want to
ask anyone for help and I thought to
myself yep
and that's when I realized I was going
through the trauma of covid and I didn't
want to use that that word depression
because it sounded like a diagnosis but
that's basically what it was it was
Little D depression so I asked him what
do you do to combat it
and he said well number one he forces
himself back into a sleep pattern number
two he lets people know on his team
listen I'm I'm going through something
I'm I'm not going to be that reliable
please just help me out here you know uh
and number three he forces himself to to
reach out to people and ask for help and
so that's what I did I forced myself to
call people and uh uh and and basically
tell people exactly how I was feeling
and ask for help
um one of the people I happen to call is
a remarkable uh executive coach name
Andrea Garfield and I hit record on my
computer and then eventually posted it
on YouTube with the hope that it might
help someone else the advice that she
gave me but I can tell you that everyone
goes through it nobody goes through it
the same way everybody goes it at
different times and the number one thing
that helped me get through it reasonably
healthily and and reasonably quickly
come in comparison was the fact that
that I I reached out to people and there
were so many people there to help me
it's such a good reminder that no matter
who you are that concept of just being
vulnerable and letting people know you
need help how powerful that can be in
terms of helping us get through that so
it's nice that you've shared that with
us
um and I love the concept of
compartmentalizing that we all think we
have to compartmentalize and control our
emotions so I love that let go let go of
the compartmentalization it's not a task
that you can actually Master that's
great it's also it's also really
important for leaders to recognize that
they lead by example and a lot of
leaders make the false mistake that they
have to pretend to be strong and in
control all the time even though they
may be struggling and suffering on the
inside because it actually backfires
because if your team is struggling
especially through something as Extreme
as what we've gone through the past 18
months that when our team who's
struggling sees us you know strong and
all the answers and optimistic and
confident all the time they start to
think it's them that if that if my
leader is is managing this then then
there's even there's something wrong
with me and so it's actually very
important from a leadership stem
leadership standpoint for those leaders
to express I'm going through something
or I need to talk to somebody or I'm
asking for help or I'm off my game
because it actually allows everybody
else to be expressive and ask their
leaders for help when they're going
through something
so powerful so powerful I totally agree
we've been doing a lot of work over the
last couple of years on focus and
focusing on what matters most
what have you been doing to help you
stay very focused notwithstanding some
of those other things you've been
working on but are there a couple
techniques you do to just make sure you
stay focused on what matters most
well having a vision is really important
I mean you know you can't go on a trip
and not know where you're driving you
know and I think unfortunately that's
how a lot of businesses run they run
visionless which doesn't mean they don't
have goals but that's like saying I'm
going on a trip I'm getting in the car
and we're going to drive 100 miles a day
that's our goal and it's like a business
we said how you know we set we set
financial goals and we keep looking at
the speedometer and seeing if we're if
we're on Pace to to hit the financial
goal and hit how much mileage we want to
cover uh uh over the course of that day
but the question is where are you going
um and so you hit all your goals and you
hit all your mileage and you hit all
your speeds and hit all your your
financial targets but to what end and so
one of the things that helps me stay
focused is a constant reminder both to
myself and to the team of of why we're
doing this in the first place because
then we may see opportunities that may
be lucrative in the short term but
they'll take a take us off path it's
Mission creep that'll eventually over
time start to to waste resources and so
sometimes times the discipline is
staying focused on something that that
we have to get done and and not get too
distracted by by even shiny objects on
the sides so so a clear sense of purpose
and a clear sense of of Just Cause has
helped me immeasurably
that's terrific and I think we're going
to start using that mission creep I like
that we do we do scope creep but I love
that concept of mission creep we really
try as well to keep focused on our North
Star to try to Anchor us but it is tough
we we do get uh distracted and and it's
a tough but very important discipline so
Suzanne is someone that's called is
going to join us for a question and I'm
going to throw uh over the question to
Suzanne Truesdale
hi thanks Sandy uh Simon lovely to meet
you thanks so much for joining us today
I lead our Small Business Solutions
sales team and in my role I lead a large
number of people leaders and just
wondering what advice you would give all
of us
um you know as we think about how we
best support our leaders to make sure
our leaders are set up really well uh to
lead effectively during these
challenging times and to really be able
to support the team members uh that they
have the privilege to lead every day
you know it's it's one of those those uh
those those questions about what is the
core of leadership and when I remember
when covet started
um a lot of people lean back on their
Humanity
um whether they were effective or
ineffective leaders prior to covid uh
many people picked up the phone called
the people in in their charge and said
are you okay how are you doing I'm just
checking in on you well that's just
called good leadership
um and so I think empathy is one of the
things that that I would recommend one
that you have empathy for those leaders
um you check in on them you know I think
the phone is a wonderful thing
um even though you may have an open door
policy remember you're assuming that
people have the courage to walk in
um uh so to checking in on people I
think is is a big deal and like I said
using the telephone but then also giving
them the skills to do the same it's very
hard to do that sometimes
um we I think in businesses can do a lot
better job of teaching our people
especially people in leadership
positions human skills I hate the term
soft skills because hard and soft are
opposites you know and not to mention
soft sounds mushy and gross right the
reality is what we need to do our jobs
and what we need to train our people to
do their jobs or hard skills these are
the physical things they need to do to
be effective at their work that we've
asked them to do and human skills which
are things like listening things like
empathy things like effective
confrontation how to give and receive
feedback how to uh uh uh things like
that
um and we don't teach those we can do a
much better job of teaching those and if
someone has the hard skills and the
human skills it makes them a much better
uh a much better leader so one is US
leading by example checking in on people
exemplifying that empathy but also
teaching them the skills that we want
them to pass down the same way
especially if they're responsible for
small businesses I mean small businesses
have gone through an unbelievable stress
that few of us can even relate to and
simply to just call up and say how are
you not offer a solution not sell
something but to just give an ear that's
called building trust so then when it
does come to actually having a solution
to when somebody wants something they're
more likely to trust you than somebody
else simply because you treated them
like a human being in in a time of
difficulty
thanks so much for that Suzanne and just
as a follow-up to that Simon um because
I think it's an excellent point around
just the empathy and calling up people
and asking how are you and just being
human
why do you think it's hard for many
leaders to just show that other side of
Being Human and you mentioned we don't
train those skills a lot of them are
innate but they can all be developed
what gets in our way of fully developing
those those attributes
well I think some people turn off the
humanity when they go to work
um you know they they they may be you
know loving parents and loving friends
and loving you know children to their
own parents and yet for some reason
there's a switch that they think that
that's irresponsible to do at work now
I'm not talking about necessarily
wearing your heart on your sleeve every
day there is something called emotional
professionalism you know if you're
having a bad day you can say listen I'm
a little off my game today but you can't
sit in a meeting with your arms folded
and be grumpy and give one word answers
that's that's emotionally unprofessional
you know you can have hard feelings but
you can't go around screaming and
yelling at people you know you can have
um so I think there's a there's
emotional professionalism but I think
for some reason especially as people
make their way up the ranks
um they think that expressing any kind
of emotion is a sign of weakness even
that word vulnerability we talk you know
it's such a common word now being talked
about in in the business world that you
have to be vulnerable to this day it
makes some people feel very
uncomfortable I don't want to be
vulnerable well all vulnerability he
means is saying things like I don't know
or I need help or I'm overwhelmed or can
you you know can you help me do this
because I don't know how to do this or
I've been promoted to a position where
maybe I need more training and the
reason we're afraid of saying that is
for fear that it makes us look weak
which will then damage our careers the
reality is the total opposite by saying
I don't know means someone can help us
but instead we choose to lie hide and
fake very often which eventually gets
revealed enough stress piled on on that
lying hiding and faking collapses either
professionally or personally we either
we either feel the stress or or the
projects that we're working on start to
go haywire and very often when we get to
those points everybody knows anyway
um and the amazing thing that I've
learned is when you say can somebody
help me we're surrounded by people who
love would love to help us they just
didn't think we needed it because we
acted as if we didn't so I think a large
part of it is is quite frankly fear fear
that if I express these things that'll
that people will think I'm not qualified
for my job
where the the the the the opposite is
true and remember when you are in a
position of leadership you don't
actually have to be better uh at doing
the job that the people you lead you
have to be responsible for taking care
of them to make sure they're good at
their job but for some reason we think
that
um I have to be better than you at your
own job because I'm the leader
completely false I just have to make
sure that you're equipped you have the
tools the training and the psychological
safety to come to be the best you can be
even if it's better than me
incredible and there's someone once uh
said to me there's freedom on the other
side of that fear so if we can get past
the fear uh there's there's freedom to
be authentic and as you often say to do
your best work so I really love that um
Shazia has another question and she's uh
is has a question for us and she's going
to
appear momentarily Shazia over to you
thanks Sandy um hi Simon thanks for
being here with us I lead the team that
supports that award-winning Broadband
networks and I'm really interested
knowing your views that what would an
effective leadership look like in
post-pandemic world
so I think uh post-pandanga post
pandemic leadership looks exactly the
same as good leadership pre-pandemic
um which is it's acknowledging the
awesome responsibility to see those
around us Rise
um one of the things we have to
acknowledge is that things have changed
I actually think there's a lot of good
um that's come out of the pandemic in
terms of leadership one as I said before
um that we relied on our Humanity for
those who did or didn't do it prior to
prior to the pandemic I hope you
continue to do it afterwards that's just
good good leadership but also we got to
see people in their own environments
right we got to see people in their
homes we got to see their kids and their
pets run in and interrupt we became a
little more patient we were okay with
things not being perfect you know it was
kind of remarkable how meetings would
get disrupted and nobody really got
bothered prior to the pandemic we would
have got annoyed by that also we didn't
even know that I that you had kids you
know so just to discover that people
have families and they have lives
outside of work I think helps us see our
colleagues
um as human beings with other other
stresses and other strains and other
things going on in their lives I hope
that all remains so post pandemic I hope
we continue to ask people how are your
kids do you have kids you know when
we're when we're uh when there's a new
hire do you have a family usually we
just get straight to work and we avoid
those things so I think seeing people as
a human being and having other lives
finding out their hobbies and dreams are
I think is a is a wonderful wonderful
thing the other thing is I think as I
said before we got a little more patient
like we understood people had stresses
at home with kids at home learning from
home and we said listen if you need to
miss this meeting we'll fill in for you
we'll fill in the gaps don't worry go do
that well I hope those things remain
that we start to recognize that part of
the work life imbalance that so many
people struggle with is actually not the
problem of the people who are trying to
find the work-life balance but it's us
who don't recognize that people have
other things in their lives we see them
only as employees so yeah I hope some of
those so some of those things that we've
learned during the the pandemic remain
really trying to emphasize leading
compassion
and I think we all want to see a world
where we're leading with more compassion
as a as a permanent change I want to
double click on something you said
earlier we've been talking about this as
well
um the no such thing as soft skills I
want to come back to that and I think we
all agree we want to say goodbye to the
term soft skills we're trying to get
that out of our vernacular now what do
you think is the most underappreciated
leadership skill you know you named a
few but the most underappreciated
uh so for me the most underappreciated
one is courage
um leadership is is hard it's extremely
hard
um you know talking to a friend of mine
who used to lead all Marine Corps
training for the United States Marine
Corps
um he said uh the number one Criterion
for being a leader is you have to want
to be one and we have to remember that
being a leader is like being a parent
you know where for a lot of people who
have a job they do their job for the
time they're at work well when you're a
parent you know there's no on off hours
you know you're a parent all the time
and you're not sure when something's
going to happen it can happen opportune
and inopportune times and you have to
react well leadership is the same you
don't get to turn on or off when you're
a leader the minute you accept a
position of leadership that's now a 24 7
job leadership is actually very very
difficult it also comes with courage to
stay the course we talked about Mission
creep to say no we're not going to
pursue that shiny object we're going to
stay on this course that takes courage
because remember so many of the
pressures put upon us both external and
from sometimes inside the company itself
with our financial incentives are
putting pressure on us not always to do
the right thing or sometimes to do the
expedient thing or the financially
effective thing but that may do damage
to the organization and to the people
later on
um but I'll benefit you know things like
that so the Courage the courage to do
the right thing the courage to have
integrity the courage to say I'm
struggling I need help the courage to
set an example the courage to build a
trusting team the courage to learn and
teach human skills
um I I think people under appreciate
just how difficult leadership is and
it's much more than simply accepting the
promotion you know it's kind of like
having a family you know you know having
the child that's the really fun easy
part like getting the promotion you know
that takes two or three minutes right
but actually raising a child that's
that's a life that's a lifelong Pursuit
kind of like leadership and and there's
no one who's an expert in leadership
I've never met a great leader ever who
consider themselves an expert in the
subject they all consider themselves
students
well it is one of those things that it's
just a pursuit of Mastery over many many
years of of self-reflection and getting
better and it really absolutely is a
journey I liked your definition of
courage that's a nice way for us to to
reflect uh on what courage means
um next question someone submitted uh is
we've had some discussions about
curiosity over the last couple of years
and sadly how um for some people
curiosity can diminish over time how
many questions we ask by the time we're
13 Cuts in half from the amount of
questions we asked when we were five so
and then I'm sure it just continues and
continues so how do we challenge
ourselves like you do to stay curious
and to overcome comfortable confirmation
biases and complacency that can just sit
in over time
uh that's such a great question and when
it becomes even more Insidious we
replace curiosity with judgment
um which which happens a lot and so the
question is how do we replace our
judgment with curiosity
um so there's a simple technique there
are simple techniques to do this um one
is write yourself a little reminder put
a little sticky on your computer that
says be curious or ask questions you'll
be amazed how well that works but
especially in times when we're judging
uh especially when we're in groups of
leaders we're in meetings you know we
can snowball into judgment really
quickly let's say someone's performance
is in Decline immediately they're lazy
you know they're stupid they don't
understand they're a problem child
um all it takes is one person to break
that judgment and say well maybe they're
going through something and there is a
technique where when you believe when
you start to form a narrative about
someone or about something that you
force yourself to come up with 21
possible Alternatives of what could be
going on in their life so are they lazy
absolutely that's absolutely a
possibility are they a problem child are
they toxic absolutely are they going
through is are there kids struggling at
school maybe do they have problems in
their family maybe someone's sick maybe
do they have medical issues that they're
hiding from us that that they're too
embarrassed about maybe like my point is
is can you go through the exercise of
writing 20 or 21 alternative stories of
what could be happening and all of a
sudden we find ourselves talking about
and treating that person differently and
it doesn't just come about people it's
also about decisions we're making at
work and all again in a meeting all it
takes is one person to raise a question
of what if
um and as Leaders The more we start
uh asking each other and ourselves what
if or what are the opportunities what
are the possibilities we'll find
ourselves doing that with our people
um that when they come to us instead of
us correcting them and telling that
they're wrong raising questions but
believe it or not simply having a little
reminder to be curious is is really
important the other thing is do things
outside of your own work
um you know people ask me what
leadership books I've read recently and
the answer is none I don't read
leadership books I like to read things
and watch documentaries that are
completely outside of the things that I
work on why because yes can I learn
things in my own discipline of course I
can but to read a whole book that I'm
either going to just completely agree
with or completely disagree with you
know for one or two nuggets seems like a
lot of effort for very little gain but
what I love is doing things outside of
work or sometimes even in work that seem
to have nothing to do with my work
because what I've learned is that we are
you know this whole idea of personal
life and work life is nonsense it's us
it's us we're going through the same
life sometimes you know it all that's
different is the table we sit at and the
clothes we wear that's the only
difference the reason our colleagues
love us is us the reason our friends
love us is us and so I think bringing
some of the Curiosities we have outside
of work to work and sharing them is
actually promoting those kinds of things
it shows us this whole uh well-rounded
human beings and it promotes us that we
have interests outside of just our work
as well
and it makes us much more interesting to
be with even at work and it's and it
helps us learn like learning happens
through experiencing different things
that are not in your day-to-day so I
really love that as well
um I used to take my team I remember oh
sorry
no keep going I was gonna sorry I
remember I called I called an essential
meeting years ago uh I called a
mandatory meeting for my my team and
they all showed up with their notebooks
and I said okay we're taking a company a
little mini off-site and I took them all
to a uh to a museum they thought they
were showing up for a meeting and we all
went to a museum and I just wanted them
to look at things differently I wanted
them to talk I wanted them to get to
know each other
um and so you know fun things like that
promote curiosity
I'm sure they went home and said best
day best day ever they ever work
Ed and
and one of the things you mentioned like
what if or we try to say things like
what if or what else or what could be
wrong with that so it's important to
remember to keep those questions
prompting us to shift our mindset and I
think as as you um Executives tend to
and leaders were rewarded for solving
problems and the faster you solve
problems the better but that that's
where the Judgment kicks in quickly so
it's a bit of an over development of the
Judgment muscle
for Speed of answering problems versus
the take your time and and be curious so
we need to work on that that right
balance so I appreciate that
so the next question that came in was a
diversity of thought it's around
diversity of thought and and how to make
sure that we have an environment that
still allows some productive conflict so
when we have diversity of thought and
and we're inclusive of different
opinions which is very much important to
us and to our workplace friction happens
cognitive friction and which builds
curiosity and creativity but it can also
impact psychological safety so can you
talk a little bit about how we can have
an environment that feels
psychologically safe but but cognitive
friction and conflicting views are okay
and they're productive
well I think again this goes back to
those human skills that we don't teach
we don't teach difficult conversations
we don't uh teach conflict resolution we
don't teach
de-escalation uh and we don't teach how
to give and receive feedback we don't
teach how to treat ideas we don't even
teach people how to have a meeting
like we don't teach any of these things
and so we're just leaving it up to
chance to hope that somebody knows what
they're doing which we would never let
somebody on the front line do we give
them tons of training on how to do their
jobs so part of it is is is the skill
set that we that we can train
um the other thing is um a lot of
leaders I think are afraid of doing
things for fear of saying the wrong
thing and again this this really lends
itself to the training we need to give
our leaders and especially I think this
was really exaggerated after the murder
of George Floyd
um where so many leaders did nothing
um they're not bad people uh they were
just so afraid of saying the wrong thing
or inflaming a situation or triggering
someone that they chose to to just do
nothing
um and so one of the things we need to
do is teach people how to lean into
tension
um uh and and to learn how to
de-escalate one's own anger or or one's
own trigger and again you brought it up
before which is and replace it with
curiosity tell me more what else I'm
struggling to under stand let me tell
you the story that's going through my
head I think is a really big one that
I've learned which is because I'm
reacting based on my own narrative right
and so they're reacting to my words or
my reaction and so one of the things
that's really helped me is to share
what's going on in my head so that
people have the context of where my
reaction is coming from let me let me
tell you what my history is and what my
background is I'm not saying this is
right or wrong I'm just telling you my
story and I'll say I had this happen in
the past where X Y and Z and so I'm
nervous at your suggestion because in
the past this has happened can you help
me resolve this or do you understand
where I'm coming from
and I think the more we can share what's
going on in the process rather than
simply you know responding with our
answers or our reactions helps the other
person see the way we're trying to see
it and it also encourages us to see the
way they're trying to see it so I think
the more we share it's that
vulnerability word again right let me
tell you my history let me tell you my
baggage let me tell you my background
let me tell you my experiences let me
tell you where my opinion is coming from
um the worst thing the one that drives
me up the wall the one that triggers me
is this is how we've always done it well
why do we do it that way because this is
how we've always done it and my rule is
if you cannot tell me why we're doing it
this way that means it's it's on the
chopping block that doesn't mean it has
to change but but I wanna I want real
explanations of why we do something this
way if somebody can't tell me then then
then it's it's open to being changed
that's a good default so we're never
going to say this is how we've always
done it for fear that our idea will be
immediately ceased uh I I really like
that yeah it's a good one and it forces
again the thoughtfulness I love the lean
in with tension or lean into to tension
and
um not always having to have your idea
perfectly formed especially in a
difficult conversation before you start
to enter the conversation and speak so
just letting people know how you're
thinking or unpacking something and
coming in safely can be super productive
versus coming in with all your thoughts
perfectly perfectly formed and Polished
and with a bow wrapped on it so I so I
like that and I can give you something
very practical if you like yeah please
um and it uh you know which is it's just
here's a technique to have a difficult
conversation which is uh and this is
what um uh this is what I did and a lot
of people I know did you know again
after the murder of George Floyd which
is I need to have a difficult
conversation I'm nervous to have this
conversation I I'm afraid I'm gonna get
things wrong and I'm afraid I might
inflame something or trigger somebody
and I'm I'm afraid of that
um but I think it's more important for
me to stumble through this conversation
because it's important for us to have
than for me to get it perfect so I need
you to just work with me and if I say
the wrong thing please please bring it
up to me and and work with me as we as
we have this conversation together well
if you can have a difficult conversation
about race you can have a difficult
conversation about anything if you need
to give somebody feedback instead of
just coming barreling in
um to say I need to have a difficult
conversation with you this is an
uncomfortable thing for me I'm afraid of
hurting your feelings I'm also afraid of
saying the wrong thing but I need to
give you this feedback you know
um or simply ask can I give you some
feedback sort of perhaps prepare someone
as opposed to I'm going to give you some
feedback the weird thing is is asking
permission uh to do something difficult
to have a difficult conversation it has
a remarkable positive impact for the
interaction you're going to have
it's so diffusing the way you've put
that the tension immediately diffuses
because our if we have empathy we feel
empathetic right away to your discomfort
and want to also make you comfortable so
it's a I think it's a great technique
I'm going to try some of these at home
with my mom's visiting us so we're gonna
see if it's still if it's not too late
to teach
resolution to an in-law that's what I
was going to ask you that's good to know
yeah
extra bonus advice for everybody today
on managing in-laws okay so someone had
a question about something that you've
quoted
um so we're going to play back one of
your quotes and want to see if you feel
differently about it now so you've been
quoted as saying
trust does not formed through a screen
it's formed across the table it takes a
handshake to bind humans and no
technology yet can replace that there's
no such thing as virtual trust and what
this individual wanted to know is has
your perspective changed given the
reality of the pandemic and we've had
such a had to do such a shift to Virtual
and hybrid work
no it Remains the Same
um uh
to it is much more efficient to build
trust
um in person uh you you don't have to do
as many things
um you know the famous violinist Isaac
Stern said music is what happens between
the notes well trust is what's built
between the meetings you know it's the
conversation walking into the conference
room it's the conversation walking out
of the conference room conference room
it's saying hi in the hallway it's
grabbing a cup of coffee it's knocking
on the door and saying do you have a
minute all of these little in seemingly
innocuous interactions over the course
of time build camaraderie and build
build trust amongst a team when we're
virtual all we have is the meeting there
is no before and after there is no
hallway talk there is no stopping by and
so to attempt to build trust virtually
actually requires more effort this is
one of the things that I think people
don't recognize when they talk about the
death of the the office they don't
realize that it if you want to do that
if you want to get rid of your office it
actually requires much more work to
start to build some of the foundations
of trust so for example you have to do
things prescriptively you can't just
allow them to happen organically
um so one of the things we do in our
organization is we have a Monday morning
huddle
where every Monday morning the whole
team comes on and we do we're not
allowed to talk about work you talk
about what's on your heart and mind and
then we answer either a funny or or
poignant question that the the Huddle
leader uh asks us and at the end we end
with a story that reminds us of why we
do what we do that anyone can present
plus we can give public high five so
congratulations to somebody for helping
us or going above and beyond we do it
publicly but the point is is there is no
discussion of work or goals or or work
challenges it's it's literally a
personal conversation we're learning
about each other and we get to hear
somebody's happy somebody's sad
somebody's struggling
but what we're doing is starting to
build trust we also uh recommend people
use the telephone more often you know
very often even when we're on Zoom
because the cameras and the screens are
not necessarily coordinated you're
looking them you know dead in the eye on
the screen but what they see is this
because you're looking at your camera or
you find yourself looking at a DOT you
know so that it appears like they're
looking at you but you're not looking at
them the point is it's it's weird
um and so we like the telephone
um people can be distracted more easily
on Zoom than they can on the telephone
you can hear when somebody's distracted
and you can say are you listening to me
when they're distracted on Zoom for some
reason we're uncomfortable saying
anything even though we can see they're
checking their email
um uh so I'm a great believer in picking
up the phone and saying how are you my
point is all of these things are still
trying to promote personal interaction
um when we don't have it organically you
can build trust but nothing replaces
that in-person thing like people talk
about the death of the business trip
sure it's dead until one person gets on
a plane to make the deal and makes the
new client feel special well
congratulations business trips are back
again
that's interesting we we noticed a group
of us came in today to the office as I
mentioned to you earlier we're here in
our office in Toronto and I think
instantly for a few of us that haven't
seen each other in 18 months
um just an incredible warmth and
reconnection that that you just can't
completely create even though we're
close there is a different feeling and
what I like about your example is
getting together on that Monday morning
and just doing a huddle how are you how
was your weekend what's going on what
are you thinking about it doesn't take
away from your success or productivity
you know people could be thinking oh my
God I don't have time for that but
you're successful Simon and you have a
successful business and no one can deny
that so this this fallacy that if I have
small talk or ask people how they're
doing or we have a 30-minute check-in on
a Monday morning on our lives is
unproductive is just not correct so I
love that we're doing it organically
thank you like I said we're doing it
organically anyway and online we just
have to do it prescriptively so instead
of five minutes five minutes five
minutes five minutes we're just doing it
an hour all on Monday plus we also
encourage our people to set up work
sessions where they turn on their
screens where they have a friend or
colleague on the screen with them and
they're working they're not working
together they're not working on the same
project it's just nice to have someone
there while you're working so again it
requires more effort
yeah and and get a dog
um okay so we have a Live question from
Chris so Chris Terrace is going to join
us
and uh Chris your question for Simon
thanks Andy and Simon I'm loving the
Insight it's uh it's super appreciated
um I I lead the strategy in Animal
Health teams and our agriculture
business unit I think this is a bit of a
fall on to your previous answer
um the pandemic has changed the way we
work and what's important to people in
some ways so in your mind what are the
biggest challenges organizations and
leaders face in response to the changing
needs and demands of our employees in
the situation that we're in now
that's such a great question and I think
it's so multi-layered or multifaceted
you know
um I think one of the things that the
the pandemic revealed quite frankly was
the weakness of so many corporate
cultures I mean we're we're seeing the
great resignation happening and if you
read articles or listen to some of the
Talking Heads you know the prevailing
thought is well they're getting you know
checks from the government so they're
not encouraged to come back to work
um or they're pursuing their dreams you
know which which we've seen as well in
our own company somebody wants to go be
a screenwriter and even though we have a
great relationship and they love their
job they they want to pursue their
dreams but the other the other thing
that I think is is underlying that it's
that it's missing that these these
commentaries are missing is that
um the cultures uh may have been weaker
than we like to think they are
um uh that the the sense of belonging
that people have when they would come to
work is actually a lot a lot more
tenuous than we'd like to believe so the
the the bond that's allowing them to go
off and do other things things is is
easily broken I think strong cultures
when there's a strong corporate culture
we recognize that I can pursue my dreams
and work because I love it here and I
know my team is supportive of me
becoming a screenwriter or something and
I can do both or even though I'm making
money potentially even more money
um there's so much more I get from my
work you know the camaraderie the love
the support I get all of this training
on how to be a better listener and a
better Communicator which is helping me
in my marriage and helping me with my
kids and I don't want to lose that plus
I I have my I have close friends at work
um and I can speak up and say hey I'm
I'm being offered more money from the
government is there anything you can
help you know the point is it becomes a
conversation rather than a rather than a
resignation so I think one of the things
that we're missing is this might be a
wake-up call for a lot of companies that
our culture is just not as strong as we
think they are you know it's been spoken
about for years that Millennials you
know and now gen Z are just not loyal to
work they bounce around from job year to
year to year well is that them or is
that us maybe maybe if we had stronger
cultures they wouldn't want to leave
maybe if we offered them more than
simply Financial incentives for hitting
certain numbers that they'd want to stay
maybe if they felt that they were
growing like as human beings there would
be things that were more appealing to
them than simply simply a bigger
paycheck somewhere else
um so I actually think it's it's a it's
a big wake-up call frankly
um uh that that we we should go back and
look at our cultures and say are we are
we as good as we think we are
thanks for your question Chris it brings
us
um we've been reflecting a lot about the
opportunities we we've been thinking and
talking about the great resignation
we've been talking about talent and cost
of talent and scarcity of certain skills
but if we go back to the basics of
assuming that compensation is fair and
good and people feel well compensated
for their work the rest is up to us in
terms of the environment that we create
and it's a lot in our hands to and we
think we've got a lot to offer in terms
of an employee employee value
proposition and so it's it's a good
opportunity to tighten that I try to
remind people that if there is a great
resignation we could be on the receiving
end of that let's try to be the net gain
you know recipients of that people may
move but let's take opportunities to
strike and grab you know disenfranchise
team members that are leaving other
organizations
so another question from a leader
um so hanif uh his violin and has a
great question for you Simon
and if over to you
hi Simon uh I I privileged to read our
International relationships so I
completely applaud getting business
travel going again so look forward to
that good question uh I have for you is
um uh organizations have been
experiencing a lot of uh labor shortages
and emerging skill gaps
um what advice do you have for us in
terms of uh workforce planning and our
and or our talent strategies
oh give me a softball away don't you
um so uh I don't think anyone's figured
this one out
um uh you know the
I think the hardest part is when there's
a labor shortage
um and the jobs that we use to easily
fill that we're now struggling to fill I
think again when it's an employee Market
I think it sends it sends a message to
us that we took a lot of things for
granted you know people need jobs we can
pay them fairly we don't have to pay
them better than sort of middle you know
um the the the kinds of things that we
can offer them become uh you know
secondary because you know we we have
all the cards we have all the power
um and so I think one of the things that
forces us to do is to start looking at
what people get from work the nature of
work has changed over the course of
decades you know work wasn't the place
that we had our sense of belonging
people you know if you go back to the
50s or 60s work was a place you made a
living and you had your sense of
belonging and Community from literally
your community you would whether it was
much more people were much more active
at church we went to bowling leagues we
were members of Shriners clubs and
volunteer groups like we had strong
senses of community and and and
belonging outside of work and over the
course of the years those things have
sort of Blended you know we've seen less
engagement in church the bowling leagues
have all but disappeared
um and now people are demanding things
that they never used to demand from work
things like belonging things like what
am I being a part of like that my
personal purpose has to be intertwined
with with the organization
um and so I think companies can start to
really look at themselves and say do we
actually have a purpose that goes beyond
our financial uh uh results do we
actually have a purpose that people can
feel a part of do we have metrics that
help people see that we're making
progress in things other than what we're
offering a shareholder or what the
bottom line is producing are our
incentive structures
um promoting things like teamwork is our
training Gonna Give You skills like how
to communicate and how to listen that
will benefit you of course at work but
you'll have a better relationship with
your spouse and your kids because of
what you're learning from your work and
when we're sitting down and talking to
people and interviewing and advertising
our jobs are we saying come work for
this great job lots of opportunity
upward Mobility get a great salary or
are we saying we um we want to make you
a better version of yourself
uh and start looking at some of
alternative things that people used to
get outside of work that they want from
work now that are we actually building
that into our work-life culture
um and I say work-life culture as if
they are one thing so I think I think we
can actually
um it starts quite quite frankly by
listening which is call the people who
have left and say can you tell me not
why you left
um can you tell me what what you're
leaving for
um you know what are you pursuing and
then everything they say don't have an
answer don't say well we already do that
don't try and fix something just say go
on tell me more I don't understand go on
tell me more and really get a full
picture of what's going on in people's
lives and what their Ambitions and
dreams are because I would I would bet
money that um uh that a lot of the
things that people feel like they're
lacking that they're looking for that
they're searching for probably at least
some of it we could help them find at
work but the problem is we don't promote
those things either in our recruitment
ads you know
um why don't we start talking about our
vision our mission and how we help
people people grow before we talk about
upward Mobility salary and where you
want to work uh uh so I think we can
start looking at some asymmetrical
things that we didn't used to look at
quite frankly they've always been there
we just didn't need to look at them
well we have been talking quite a bit
about the power of our social purpose
and being a social purpose-driven
company and how much more that just even
seems to resonate with as you mentioned
earlier Gen Y and now gen Zed gen C uh
and we just have to be better thank you
we just have to be better at leaders
about talking about those things
um because I think we've underestimated
at times that people want those things
we get right to the technical things
about what they're gonna what training
they might get what benefits they might
get what their comp looks like what
their bonus program looks like which is
all important but it seems to be that
it's just table Stakes those things have
to be good and fair
um but we've got to really leverage our
social purpose uh our culture our values
the opportunities of working a team that
that we have as as much more important
than we have in the past so we're going
to build that into our to our our
recruitment
at the risk of distracting only because
I keep having thoughts I can give you a
funny example
feel free to interrupt me if I go down a
rabbit hole
um uh so true story you know a bunch of
military military recruiters
um who are show up at a high school
and the Air Force recruiter stands up
with a beautiful PowerPoint and shows
what you can get from the Air Force
which sounds very similar than to what a
what a corporate recruiter might do here
are all the things you know you can get
from us
um the Marine the the Navy recruiter
stands up and says forget forget what
the Air Force said let me tell you why
the Navy's better and again here are the
things that that that you can expect to
get
um uh the Army recruiter does the same
thing beautiful PowerPoint shows the
kind of life you're going to live
finally the marine recruiter stands up
with no PowerPoint stands on the edge of
the stage looks around the room sort of
takes takes the room in and says nope I
don't want any of you
he says you have to understand the
Marine Corps is the single most
difficult thing you'll ever do in your
life emotionally and physically and I
don't think there's anyone in this room
strong enough to be in my Marine Corps
he says if you think I'm wrong I'm
standing at the back of the room
and the point is he puts a stake in the
ground of what the culture is like and
he's recruiting to the culture not to
the benefits or the trappings or the
perks and for us to have a clear sense
of what our culture is like and recruit
to people who are going to be additive
to our culture which I think is more
important than belonging to our culture
this idea of you're a bad cultural fit
you're a good cultural fit we want
people who are going to contribute and
help us build upon our culture cultures
are living breathing animals and giving
people an opportunity to contribute
rather than simply fit in I think is
something very exciting for a lot of
people especially young people we want
to know that our effort and our energy
contributes to more than simply helping
making us or a company money
well you know I love the
the tribute to the culture versus fit to
the culture because when you talk about
diversity and inclusiveness if at the
end of the day you're still looking for
people to fit your culture perfectly
that's a bit oxymoronic right we we
actually want you to contribute to
making our culture better and better and
better versus just fit into us which is
a little static so that's a nice way to
think about it
correct okay I want to come back to your
book uh the infinite game which we
talked about a couple weeks ago we've
that we unpacked in a couple of round
tables back in 2019 so lots of
conversations about it
um so someone who was really paying
attention
um wants to double click on existential
flexibility
and you talked about that quite a bit in
that book and so that's the ability to
make a 180 degree shift in your business
when it's required and you talk a little
bit about
Kodak as a company that had a finite
mindset and paid a significant price
which we all know of so what are the
signs in an organization that a shift
might be required and how can leaders
determine
when to make it
so that's such a great question so
um it goes back to that Vision again
right which is if we don't know the
direction we're going in then we won't
know when we have to change then uh uh
change path
um because we're too busy counting that
we're going really fast and things are
going really well and on paper Kodak
things were great except if you could
see the long term you could see that
they were going to go off the path you
know at some point
um you know one of the bigger challenges
I think is all of people who made those
decisions had long retired and and moved
on after Kodak finally went uh uh
bankrupt
um so I think Vision vision is the big
one to know because there are changing
uh there's changes in culture there's
changes in technology there's changes in
politics there's changes in people's
tastes that have to allow us to evolve
and change and how we're advancing our
cause
um and very very often companies become
stuck in the technologies that they've
invested in they've become stuck in the
money they've already spent or the hours
they've already spent investing in one
strategic Direction even though
everybody kind of knows it's wrong but
we just don't have the courage to uh to
walk away from it and there's that word
again courage to cut our losses and say
I I think this is the wrong thing to do
I think we need to change directions I
think Sandy's not hearing me
I can wave
so one second Simon all good
oh
there we go test test can you hear me
can you hear me
I can hear you not in my ear but I can
hear you anyways now so we're good great
okay you hear me all right so that I can
hear you fine yeah so the whole I think
the whole idea was was was how to make
an existential Flex how you know
um well very often you go I mean it's
actually the sum total of a lot of
things we've been talking about courage
is definitely one of them you know
walking away from existing uh investment
um even though we know it's eventually
gonna fall off a cliff where somewhere
else is better we just but we've already
spent all this money we can't just walk
away from it well you can
um uh uh uh the other thing we talked
about was curiosity
um which is we have to be curious about
um what's changing in the world
technology and otherwise tastes
Lifestyles and not just reacting to them
are these things permanent I think a lot
of people are making shifts in during
covid that are reactions predicting as
to what what uh what the world's gonna
be like really when it's not the case
um and uh I think the other one is
worthy rivalry quite frankly
um which is the other Concept in the
book which is instead of reacting to
competition I think studying competition
and and seeing how they're doing
especially startups you know startups
very often small companies are they run
generally by younger people they're
generally seeing things that older
companies and older people are missing
and it doesn't mean we have to buy them
it doesn't mean we have to like them it
doesn't mean we have to agree with them
but I think we should probably pay
attention to them because it was the
movie and television industry that
ignored Netflix and it was the
publishing industry that ignored Amazon
and you know uh uh uh Myspace had no
idea that Facebook was even a thing you
know and the problem is they were all
comparing themselves to the large
incumbents in other words it's old you
know in stodgy companies comparing
themselves to Old stodgy companies
thinking that that will make them help
help them be reactive and then at least
pay attention to small companies you
know go go be a part of those
um even have a little fun to invest just
for fun it's not a significant thing as
part of a business plan but it's just
helping you keep your your fingers on
the pulse and gets you in the circuit
visit visiting you know all the the
various uh silicon valleys that that
have propped up all across the world and
around uh different areas of both our
countries
um uh I I think that's really really
important understanding what the what
the trends are not reacting to them
learning and studying them and seeing
what what is actually sticky
I think the studying is really important
we um we try really hard not to focus
just on the traditional Telco
competitors we have to watch them of
course because we're compared to them in
our industry but they're not our
Obsession uh we try to look around the
corner and understanding what other
technology disrupters are going to come
into our space and what other disruption
can we do with our technology but it's
an important reminder not to have the
arrogance that you're just comparing all
the time and contrasting uh at every
detail but what can we study so I like
the word study versus be threatened by
or just arrogant
what can we learn and and your your use
of disruption is important because any
kind of disruption or strategic shift
does come at a cost it does increase
stress on the organization in the short
term it does cost money it probably will
have some short-term financial
implications and a lot of executives are
very afraid of those declines you know
the example that I wrote about in in the
book CVS choosing to stop selling
cigarettes in all of its stores for
example came at came at a short-term
Financial cost it was the right
strategic shift not exactly an
existential flex but a very difficult
strategic decision nonetheless any kind
of I I talked to a CFO once and I said
what are your priorities this is for a
large company and he said my priorities
are Innovation and efficiency and I
smiled and said well good luck with that
you know because Innovation is not
efficient you know you you know I guess
sometimes it can be but the very nature
of innovation means experimentation and
experimentation necessarily means
failure and wastage
um and by wastage I mean we're learning
lessons uh I don't like the term failure
because you should be learning from it
um but uh but the point is is you can't
have Innovation and efficiency at the
same time it doesn't exist
yeah we try really hard to also be
mindful about that notion of
experimentation try experiment start
small if it works scale it if it doesn't
work let it go and keep moving and even
large companies can do that so that's a
it's an important muscle to have we
actually talked about your CVS example
in our round tables because it was a
good example of doing things that
everybody thought was just bound to fail
the competitors aren't doing it they're
going to take your market share the
board thought they were crazy and it
ended up opening up all these other
partners not only did it did they were
they successful they gained market share
they went into other opportunities they
had new partners and moved their whole
and align themselves with their Vision
which was a little bit more healthier
than the whole tobacco piece correct
although it was a big part of their
financial success ever contributed to
them and they're still doing you know
very well
to get through all the courageous and
difficult things they had to do
um Dave is up next and he has a question
for you Simon
hi Simon hey Dave thank you so much for
being here today
I'm proud to lead the business customer
experience team and we're focused on
delivering Technology Solutions for
businesses all across Canada
and speaking of what we can learn from
our competitors I wanted to ask if
you've started to see evidence of
publicly traded companies that are being
rewarded for advancing a social purpose
while caring about their people and
while also driving shareholder return
that seems like the trifecta of things
that we really want to do at Telus
um can you share any examples
yeah it's it's they're being rewarded by
employees
they're being rewarded by customers I
think that Wall Street still is not a
huge fan uh mainly because the incentive
structures of of the analyst Community
are not based on your company advancing
its social purpose but rather your
company hitting their predictions
um I'll tell you one company that I
think has done a good job but they had
to they've had to have the courage to
speak their mind and stand up to Wall
Street WD-40 as in WD-40 the lubricant
company so it's not a glamorous product
um was on one of their financial calls
one day and the analyst said you've
missed your numbers and the CEO Gary
Ridge said no I missed your numbers my
numbers are fine
um and I think that's that's part of it
which is recognizing that the pressures
that we Face from the public markets
um don't encourage us to make the
decisions that are sometimes good for
our company and good for advancing our
social uh purpose but I think it's
important to point out the example as we
just did about CVS which is Wall Street
absolutely punished them berated them
criticized them criticized the decision
um punish them with their their Buy sell
recommendations
um and yet they were rewarded heavily by
employees the love that they got the
Loyalty That Grew and uh and from
customers you know the average uh the
average sale at a CVS store went up
um not to mention the fact that they
made people healthier so I think the
question is where do you want your
reward from over the course of time if
you're if your employees and customers
are rewarding you over the course of
time then the shareholder will benefit
that's the great irony so I actually
think the ones that are that are having
a good time of it are the ones that are
starting to figure out ways how to brush
up against wall Street's pressures um
there's one company I know it's a very
large uh it's a it's a large Airline
um so many many many tens and tens and
tens and tens of thousands of employees
uh if not more
um they've done something very
sophisticated where they've bifurcated
their shareholder base
um so they looked at their shareholders
who are the long-term investors the ones
who believe in the management team the
ones who believe in the vision the ones
when they talk about having a social
Mission they they agree with it when
when things go badly they don't just
dump the stock they stick with them
because they believe in in the in the
leadership and the vision and and the
ones who are just the the fair weathered
fans the one who put pressure on them to
make short-term numbers they've
literally gone through the whole list
and bifurcated the groups so when they
say we're shareholder driven they are
but only one side of only one side of
the of the page and they literally work
to ignore this group
um and so I I think that what you want
to do is is find the shareholders who
who do believe in you and they will be
rewarded
um the irony is is the short-term one
will get rewarded anyway because they're
Fair withered fans
um younger companies I think some of the
young uh some of the younger
um uh public companies uh uh uh Airbnb
for example very very strong social
Mission they're in the news right now
for providing free housing for Afghan uh
refugees in the United States and no not
just in the United States around the
world forty thousand they're going to
host uh for free
uh they're going to pick it up there so
I think I think that some of the younger
companies which we should probably pay
attention to
um they're doing it
um and I think Wall Street treats them a
little differently because they're young
it's interesting you know we as you say
that we have shareholders that um are
not only accepting but they're pushing
us to be responsible from a social
purpose perspective they're pushing us
to be environmentally responsible and to
have a sustainability strategy they're
pushing us to have diversity goals and
want to see diversity and inclusion uh
and diversity goals quite frankly at our
board level at our management level so
we have seen a rise in social activism
in the shareholder community and that's
exciting because as you said if the more
shareholders that we have that have
those shared set of values with us the
more tolerant they'll be of any changes
we make in Direction and they'll want to
stick with us for deeper purposeful
reasons than you know what you would
call finite gains in their Investments
so we can't ignore the other ones but I
think it's it's a nice if the IR team is
listening to me in the finance guys
right now
um we have there they work very hard on
this message because they're pushed for
these messages and this just isn't it's
good to hear that we can just continue
to build up that excitement from our
shareholder community and and get that
people that want to be with us for the
infinite game so that's exciting
my opportunity and the opportunity
the opportunity is to lead right I think
as you pointed out a lot of companies
are responding in other words they're
doing it not because they necessarily
believe in it or maybe they believe in
it now but they're responding to
pressure right being Purpose Driven
putting the environment first you know
they hadn't thought about it until the
pressure began and that pressure very
often came from customers and employees
first and then eventually trickled out
into into the investor community so I
think the ones to the opportunity to be
a leader is somebody is to be a company
that's willing to make a decision first
that others will follow you know you're
a leader when when others follow you it
doesn't mean you're the best of the
brightest but it means you set the trend
so I I agree with you I think a lot of
companies are going this way but you
know the ones that I'm paying attention
to which were the ones that are reactive
and then there's two kinds of reactive
reactive because we have to but we don't
really believe in it and react it
because you know what we really should
and we actually do believe in it yeah
yeah yeah that's exciting that's very
exciting for us
um so
let me come to
the question that we're all thinking
about and then there's one more question
from one of our team members can you
share what you're working on we haven't
been able to get this out of your team
so can you share what you're working on
what's occupying your brain as you're
thinking about the world what what can
we expect coming we're going to plan our
next leadership round table so we want
to know
what's the next bit of exciting things
coming
or you don't want to talk yeah I mean
happy to talk about it
um you know uh I'm now trying to tackle
some very very difficult problems I'm
working behind the scenes on some really
really hard problems where I can really
roll my sleeves up you know I've I've
been out there preaching a message for
so long and I'm very lucky that that I'm
very grateful that you know amongst my
oh I've lost okay I'm back again
um you know because my books and my
talks
um uh you know my my message can spread
without me being on stage the whole time
um and so now I'm spending considerable
more time working behind the scenes
again which is sort of my happy place
one of the things I'm working on is
police reform we formed a group called
The Curve which is the most
forward-thinking Progressive police
Chiefs and sheriffs in the country who
um we're finding ways that we can uh
that we can change the culture of
policing in the United States uh for the
better it's been remarkable and I'm
learning a ton and some meeting some
really great people so that's one of the
things I'm working on
um in terms of sort of more or bookie
kind of things I've become very
interested in the concept of control
especially during covid and and uh and
the rise of black the black lives matter
movement
um uh and and what we saw happening on
January 6 in the United States you know
when people feel in control and when
people feel out of control how does that
affect how we view each other and how we
view ourselves and how do companies or
or even uh our governments what are they
doing that make us feel in control and
and what I've seen is people who feel
out of control feel a lack of control of
their own lives or their own Destinies
it actually promotes things like
conspiracy theory
um also inside companies when we feel
out of control it actually promotes
things like office politics
um it's a fascinating thing inside a
company you know uh when we give people
agency just you know more more
opportunity to decide what they want to
do and how to do their jobs where
they're being told how you should do
your job and this is the only way to do
it it actually not only increases stress
but it actually increases
um uh office politics and people
exerting
um uh control over people because they
try to have control at any sort of thing
so I I there are no fully formed ideas
yet but I'm really fascinated by this
idea of people they sound very good they
we absolutely can all I think relate to
this concept of losing control uh as we
all have in the last 18 months of things
that we just assumed to be natural and
normal so we'll be excited to see some
of your work on that and certainly on
the police reform
um what an important topic so that'll be
exciting I'm sure you're gonna have a
big impact
we'll be watching So Lisa has the
closing question for the day and I think
it's just a really nice summary of um
how we see you Simon and So Lisa I'm
going to turn it over to you to take us
home with a really great question
I feel privileged Sandy that I get the
last word I'm excited Simon thanks so
much for for sharing your time with us
you've just given us so much to think
about today I I support our contact
center agents around the globe that are
working day in and day out to give our
our customers an amazing experience
here's my question for you
um I think you describe yourself as an
unshakable optimist what keeps you so
optimistic
uh so there's two things uh one goes
back to that sense of vision and purpose
um which is the the the metaphor is it's
a light at the end of the tunnel uh you
know the vision that I have I imagine a
world so there's that word it lives in
my imagination I imagine a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired feel
safe wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do
um that is my light at the end of the
tunnel optimism is not naive it's not
blind positivity
um I can say I'm in a dark tunnel we're
in a dark tunnel I don't know how long
we're going to be in this tunnel it's
going to be difficult it's going to be
stressful but I know that if we stick
together and work together we will we
will get to that light at the end of the
tunnel and we will come out stronger
than when we went in so one of the
things is absolute fixation on the on
the future I'm I'm working to build
um that definitely helps and the other
one is the strength of relationships
um you know sort of these are nice
bookends you know where we started this
conversation
um calling my friend the active duty
military friend about uh about the need
to reach out to help for help
um and I think the strength of our
relationships when we have people in our
Lives who say I believe in you I've got
your back
um even if this thing goes south I'll
still be there with you
um those are the things that give
courage those are the things that breed
optimism I for one do not believe that
that courage or even optimism are just
internal things you dig down deep and
find the courage I just don't think
that's how it works courage is external
um you know the reason we have the
courage to jump out of an airplane is
because the parachute on our back it's
the external thing
um uh the the Navy Seals are seen as one
of the highest performing organizations
in the planet and a former seal was
asked
um you know what kind of person makes it
into the seals and he said I can't tell
you what kind of person makes it in but
I can tell you what kind of person
doesn't make it in he said the Star
College athlete that's never really been
tested to the core of their being none
of them make it in he said the preening
leader likes to get delegate everything
none of them make it in he said the guys
that show up with hunking muscle hulking
muscles covered in tattoos to show how
strong they are how tough they are none
of them make it in he said some of the
guys who make it in are skinny and
scrawny he said some of the guys you'll
see shivering out of fear
he said but one thing they all have in
common when they're emotionally
exhausted when they're physically
exhausted when they have nothing left to
give somehow some way they're able to
dig down deep inside themselves and find
the energy to help the person next to
them
it's about service and so the more
opportunities I have to serve others and
the more people have surrounded me who
believe in me and who are there to to
look after me and protect me when I'm at
my lowest
um it's actually quite easy to say
optimistic about a bright future
well that's great and thank you for the
question Lisa and Lisa you should know
is is an optimist so it was a great way
to end this and you know giving where
you live giving back to the community
doing uh service for others is a great
way as we all know and feel every day to
stay optimistic and to feel positive and
hopeful and certainly re-energizing so
thank you for that inspiration Simon
we're at the end of our time and we've
been able to touch base on quite a
number of topics including certainly
what it means to lead during these
challenging times and into the future
some things to expect some Workforce
Trends some risks and certainly most of
all some opportunities
Simon thanks for sharing your really
valuable insights and perspective and
it's a gesture of our gratitude Telus is
pleased to make a one thousand dollar
donation to rambert uh in your name
thank you and for those who are not
familiar with rambert uh it's a uh it's
based on the South Bank in London and
it's actually one of the most uh world's
most diverse company of dancers they
transform everyday Spaces by making
dance that's inspiring adventurous
Dynamic and relevant and
offer performances dance and wellness
classes courses for people of all ages
and all abilities so again Simon thank
you for your team and to you for making
this event possible
thanks so much for having me take care
of yourself take care of each other it's
it's been a real Joy thanks so much for
having me